über diesen umgang insbesondere bei der
frage
abweichender meinung was sie besonders
bewegt als arzt in leipzig und das
interessiert uns fasste aus ihrer sicht
momentan passiert ja abweichende meinung
ist man ja immer gleich wenn man sagt
okay ich irgendwie hier nicht oder ich
sehe das kritisch wir müssen über solche
dinge sprechen und man wird immer ganz
schnell in eine ecke geschoben ob das
rechtsradikale träge oder ähnliches ist
also wie gesagt ich impfe auf und diese
woche war für mich eine besondere woche
weil ich plötzlich gemerkt hat es gibt
in der gesellschaft was was ausspricht
ein kleines pflänzchen der hoffnung ich
habe von dem landrat in bautzen gehört
der mit den spaziergängern am montag
gesprochen hat ich habe von dem
oberbürgermeister aus kamenz gehört der
die spaziergänger ins rathaus eingeladen
hat gesagt wir müssen reden und er hat
sich dann am nächsten montag wieder vor
seinem rathaus gestellt und eine ganz
tolle rede gehalten um genau diese
spaltung zu überwinden wir haben als
gruppe in leipzig ein aufruf gestartet
für mehr toleranz und mitmenschlichkeit
und haben zu einem runden tisch
eingeladen und der ist letzte woche
freitag vonstatten gegangen wir haben
auch das große glück dass wir denen
veröffentlicht konnten seit montag wo es
darum geht dass man wirklich mal in
einer gesprächsrunde miteinander spricht
ohne schaum vom mund ohne dann immer
gleich in eine ecke impfgegner geschoben
zu werden die dinge die fakten auf den
tisch zu bringen und sachlich vernünftig
wie es ist einfach gehört in einer
demokratie miteinander umzugehen
wertschätzend ohne beleidigung und
ähnlich ist und warum wir das so wichtig
ist weil ich merke das sind eigentlich
die normalen grundlagen einer demokratie
und ich habe gemerkt das ist nicht mehr
normal was hier gerade passiert ich habe
die sache ist für mich
schön ich habe in meiner ganzen
ich weiß nicht mehr von uns altersmäßig
aber ich habe meiner 40-jährigen
mindestens 40 jährigen berufslaufbahn
ich habe noch nie in deutschland erlebt
und ich bin am klavier längst im beruf
noch nie erlebt dass abweichende
meinungen und wenn jetzt das wort
alternativ stadt meine nicht
alternativen
alternative meinungen zweitmeinungen
dass dies mit solcher vehemenz
diskreditiert und
weg geschoben worden sind denn es gibt
einfach egal wer welche meinung hat und
hier das beste beispiel wie können sie
kunden offen reden also die wahlsendung
also sie sind bin ich kratze haltung
aber hier disco geht nicht überall ja
ich will zunächst mal bevor wir die
verträge sind interessanten punkt
weitere ich muss nochmal darauf
zurückkommen auf meine these zweig muss
weg ich darauf warten dass wir ein fall
ist als liberale politiker müssen sie
nicht und auch nein will mir einiges
bitte bald zurückkehren wir sind jetzt
beim thema meinungsfreiheit
sie können dann einmal ganz schön keine
sekunde an einem thema das hat er drauf
antworten aber würde mir nicht gestattet
es ist wieder im griff hat man alle
maßnahmen auf rechtmäßigkeit prüfen und
als zweig eingeführt wurde da was
deutlich sodass man gesehen hat auf den
intensivstationen gab es immer weniger
platzte es wurden viele operationen
abgesagt für andere krankheiten zb weil
sehr viele besonders in sehr hohen maße
ungeimpfte da intensivstation plätze
belegt haben jetzt sehen wir bei dem
intensivstation staton geht es gott sei
dank endlich zurück es geht aber anders
jetzt ja denn du musst du jetzt trotzdem
beim hsv bleiben
das war der hammer noch sagen was man
will kann man etwa hier auf jeden fall
ich glaube aber wenn man meinung
vorträgt die vom menschen abweichen da
muss man auch widerspruch ertragen und
ich bin etwas überrascht ihr statement
wir müssen uns für mehr toleranz
einsetzen aber ich frage sie wo es ihre
toleranz gegenüber jenen die zu ihnen
kommen und sagen ich habe die freie
entscheidung getroffen ich möchte mich
impfen lassen da müssen sie doch auch
die land gegenüber den sein und sagen
ich respektieren sie die freie
entscheidung und ich würde sie im für
respektiere die freie entscheidung
ich vermittle einen termin es gibt
genügend praxen wo sie geimpft werden
können das ist kein problem da dürfen
sie hingehen man muss auch dazu sagen
impfen ist jetzt nicht so wie bei
tetanus also das braucht auch schon ein
bisschen vorbereitung man muss dafür
extra sprechstunde machen um das
ordentlich zu machen um als auch eine
ordentliche aufklärung zu machen und ich
verwehre keinem diese impfung
sie kriegen eine beratung ja natürlich
für euch die selber nicht durch das
interessant zu sehen es gibt also nicht
nur menschen die entschlossen sind sich
nicht impfen zu lassen ich habe nicht
den eindruck dass die wesentlich
abnehmen sondern ich habe den eindruck
dass die impfkampagne der
bundesregierung zusammengebrochen ist da
tut sich kaum mehr was das ist alles
erschlafft wieder bundeskanzler auch und
sein gesundheitsminister jetzt gibt es
stellen aber fest es gibt auch ärzte und
menschen medizinischen personal die das
ganz genauso sehen die also auch sagen
ich empfinde ich und ich wahrscheinlich
sagen sie auch ich werde nie impfen das
konnte oder ich werde sofort wieder
anfangen zu impfen wenn die impfung eine
stellenwert hat wie eine ganz normale
grippeschutzimpfung wie eine tetanus
impfung wo wirklich diese freiheit da
ist wo ich nicht sagen muss er kommt
jetzt und weiß nicht genau unter welchen
druck punkte also ja ich würde sagen das
ist ja nur deshalb weil sie ein gutes
beispiel dafür sind dass es solche
meinungen in der mitte der gesellschaft
auch im medizinischen apparat gibt und
wenn ich das richtig einschätze sind sie
weder rechtsradikal noch ein
verschwörungstheoretiker ich möchte
einmal zuvor fans zurück vorfeld
eigentlich gab es doch noch nie so viele
möglichkeiten
seine ihre meinung zu sagen nein es gibt
facebook es gibt instagram es gibt
soziale medien das gab es doch früher
alles nicht warum haben sie dann
trotzdem das gefühl sie können ihre
meinung nicht mal so richtig sein
richtig man kann natürlich die meinung
sagen man muss halt bloß dann aushalten
dass man zum beispiel nicht bei mir sich
ganz konkreter freie nachher aber dass
in anderen berufen dass man das ja eine
stelle gekündigt wird oder dass man als
pfleger nicht mehr rein sagt dass man
dies nicht darf dann ist man sich sicher
jetzt wird's weiter war es nichts nichts
radikales auch nicht rechtzeitig oder
linksradikale sondern die man es gibt
viel zensur bei youtube werden einfach
ganze ding
auch radikales sagen dürfen die
meinungsfreiheit hat kein geländer oder
so
sonntag unterscheiden muss zwischen
meinungsfreiheit und zwischen falschen
tatsachenbehauptung also ich glaube da
muss man schon eine gewisse
unterscheidung von richtig guter grund
da würde ich da wir uns selber drauf
gekommen alles gut läuft ist noch einmal
weil ich glaube viele leute nehmen sehr
schnell das war zum beispiel zensuren
dem mund oder ich höre ganz auf zb vom
thema angeblich hätten wir keine
demokratie oder so und ich finde das
ehrlich gesagt den menschen gegenüber
die wirklichen die wirklich so erfahren
wirklich nicht in der demokratie geben
wenn ich das nicht vorher land würde ich
sagen es wurde baut ist ja das würde ich
mir
ein anderes thema das ist bei anderen
ganz anders gekommen wie kommen wir
gleich darauf was ihnen persönlich
passiert ist aber um noch mal ein
bisschen genereller zu bleiben was
erleben sie dabei freunden bei denen die
mit denen sie zu tun haben warum gibts
da die sorge dass etwas passieren könnte
meine these nicht bei der impfung ist
aber der meinung ganz generell bei der
meinungsfreiheit bei der frieden bei der
frage ob man noch die mal sagen sie
haben das in meiner tradition war ich
spd und er links so kann hingegen sei
syrien oder links von der spd so also
ich bin wird es nicht in gefahr ich im
moment zur afg überzulaufen sage ich
einfach mal laut aber trotzdem ist die
afc immer von ein paar millionen leuten
gewählt die sagen irgendwas sie machen
also ziemlich heftige opposition die
macht ja sonst keiner mehr weil die alle
weitgehend einer meinung sind also kann
ich nicht oder demonstrationen ich kann
nicht sagen das sind lauter
rechtsradikale alle hüte schmuggler
spinner durch tröpfchen das ist etwas
was haben uns immer denn sieht man jetzt
mal den demonstrationen wie beide unna
massen abermals gegen was auch immer
sondern die müssen reden können ich
würde persönlich aus der afc elemente
entfernen die völkischen und und und
hetzen übrigen haben wir gerade erlebt
dass ich noch radikalere dort
durchgesetzt haben gegen vermeintlich
gemäßigte das haben wir beim thema
mieten und hörte erlebt hatte den mann
als rechtsradikal bezeichnen muss
durchgesetzt ja aber erneuten hat ihnen
in die position gebracht sich
durchzusetzen er hat ihn gefördert er
hat ihnen auch gebraucht eine ganze zeit
heute ist der saulus zum paulus geworden
denn darf man nach ernsten aber ich habe
immer noch nicht ganz verstanden einfach
wird's was was passiert dann aus ihrer
sicht den menschen die sich äußern in
einer weise wie es vielleicht der
mehrheitsmeinung ja ganz einfach wenn
wenn zb einer trainer sagt ich werd ich
möchte mich nicht gerne impfen lasse
nicht kennen aus der familie aus der
weiteren verwandtschaft dann kriegt der
schwierigkeiten im beruf wenn einer sagt
ich bin nicht einverstanden mit der
impfpflicht wenn einer sagt ich hätte
ich werde meine politisch dieses und
jenes dann kriegt er schwierigkeiten als
er kriegt zürich awp der kriegt die wird
vielleicht gekündigt wird gebeten zu
kündigen